this is a fast-paced program 32-year-old
jonathan caesar is a full-time nursing
student at arizona college of nursing at
the las vegas campus in the southwest
part of town i come to the school seven
o'clock in the morning like when we open
and i stay here until like 5 30. put the
blood pressure cuff on him he's also a
father to two beautiful little girls i
let them know that i'm i'm gonna be able
to help people and in his free time
competes and mixed martial arts i get
asked that question a lot as well as
like you know
how are you why do you do do you fight
and then you also do nurse so like what
are you going to like beat them up and
then patch them up and it's that
diversity among its 350 students that
this school of nursing brings to area
hospitals many of our hospital
facilities feel that that is one of our
biggest strengths the school's dean dr
jill rankin adds arizona college of
nursing also provides an accelerated
bachelor's of science of nursing program
students here compete nine semesters in
a three-year time frame instead of four
dr rankin says her school is bringing
reinforcements at a crucial time the
best next generation of nursing students
to come and help them with the fight
of the covet pandemic we know they're
tired and we know they're stressed but
we want them to know that we are behind
the scenes working hard hospitals across
the valley are recruiting these students
prior to graduation jonathan completed
his clinical rotation at mountain view
and sunrise he works part-time with
community ambulance and he is set to
graduate this summer i want to be a
trauma nurse more determined than ever
made me double down like you know what
like this is real and like people are
going to really need they're going to
need help more than ever